welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and your savior is
here Loki is back and episode one of
season 2 is now out online packed with
Easter eggs lots of timey wiy wibbly
wobbly stuff and a big post credit scene
I have to
say over the next eight weeks I'm going
to be breaking down the series frame by
frame to bring you all the comic book
references and things you missed in it
we'll then be following that with mty
handling the big Theory and Analysis
video so make sure you subscribe to
never miss a video anyway I'm going to
stop wasting time I just want to stop it
right now and get right into
it now as always we begin with a Marvel
studios's logo which turns green and
gold just like how it did in the first
season as always they've updated this
slightly with us now getting a clip of
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 and he
who remains in the a he who remains
looms large over this season in with the
Statue of Kang being how we left things
last time this is where we pick up and
mirroring how we zoomed in on the Statue
last time here we start off by zooming
out now we can actually see these
statues LED throughout the TVA and when
Loi runs into Hy B15 you can catch one
behind her after Loki crashes the car we
can also see several of them in a line
outside the window creating this idea
that he's a dictator looking over the
domain his eyes are the first thing we
really get focus on and there Stone
carvings give the impression that he's
Unbreaking able and the stonework here
resembles an Egyptian style statue with
a texture reminding me of how the Sphinx
looks the Sphinx is actually really
important with Kang as the shiy travel
timing resembled this as well this had a
fixed nose on it and it actually
appeared in the void during Loki season
1 I think it also Echoes the Colossus of
roads which was one of the Ancient
Wonders of the World the clothes he's
wearing are also more like kangs rather
than he remains showing that we're in a
slightly different time period now I
think these statues might get pulled
over at some point and it could Echo
things like the top Ling of Saddam
Hussein's regime now as we learn we're
actually dealing with two points in time
here with Loki constantly being pulled
back and forth between them the first of
these is back when can control the TVA
before he wiped everyone's memories and
then built the timee keepers the L of
these is in the aftermath of season 1
with it being where Mobius and B15 saw
the timeline falling apart we will talk
about the indicators of this throughout
the video but there's some really cool
things they do in the past that then
affected future when we pull out we then
see Loki run in front of the statue
possibly foreshadowing where things are
going to go I think that he'll actually
take over the position of he who remains
and this may symbolically show where
we're going with this series now the
attention to detail here is really spot
on with lokie even carrying the cut on
his arm that he had in the last entry
when you think about it the man's had a
pretty crazy couple of weeks with being
a number of changes that have happened
in his life first the whole thing went
down with the Avengers which took place
roughly a year after thought after
grabbing the Tesseract he managed to
escape and then was taken by the TVA
before he worked his way up to he
remains we're now here with endgame and
Loki season one all taking place over a
couple of days for him pretty wild time
but they've done a terrific job of
lining things up and elevating this
Beyond what's come before now ly does a
Fifth Element and jumps over the edge
which is where he lands in what looks
like a TVA post truck the outfit the
woman wears is similar to a UPS one and
there's a potential Easter egg with the
carts number this says 435 and in
fantastic 4354 the group tried to escape
the TVA through using a Time
train I will talk about how this comic
plays in stuff later on but they they do
have a couple of references to it so I I
think it might be alluding to that
anyway they crash into the Kang's statue
cracking its face carrying this idea as
Empire is going to come crumbling down
this is echoed in the crack in the floor
which holds the TVA logo and then later
on in the the destruction of the
timekeeper mural now from here we cut to
Casey cleaning the floor which shows
this is before he was promoted to work
the desk this is actually the same room
that he met Loki in during season 1 and
Loki said give me the Tesseract or I'll
gut you like a fish Casey what's a fish
Casey's also rocking an 80s Walkman and
as we later see all attack at the TVA is
modified stuff from the past later on
when Loki appears we see him getting ink
in his pocket which might be a way in
future that differentiate the two
versions now number of things happen
here that affect the future and explain
why certain things in the TVA change
firstly is the glass which the car
crashes through and later all these
windows get replaced with metal paneling
the TV is also smaller and more
spherical looking with it eventually
falling down from the ceiling and
cracking off the floor this is later
replaced with the more widescreen one
with a crack on the floor also carrying
over two this helps to show the
different points in time which logies
constantly pull back and forth between
also huge shout outs to Mt for pointing
out the TV itself begins glitching which
can be seen as something similar to
Loki's time slipping now this effect is
like what we see in the spiderverse
films but there's actually a deeper
reason for why it looks This way
everything gets sort of a bit sort of
spaghetti like and I was thinking is
that cuz they're going to the
Past [__] sake now during Quantum
Mania sorry during Quantum Mania an
Antman got stuck in a probability storm
with one of his versions getting Tor to
Ribbons this is like what we see happen
here but as we know Loki gets pulled
back together now endgame show that time
travel has to happen at a Quantum level
and this is due to being where one jumps
back and forth through time the
probability storm happened in the
quantum realm as well with this all
taking place at a molecular level thus I
think this might be happening at that
point with ly being pulled down to a
Quantum level before then expanding at
another point in time I also think the
TVA could exist down there as well and
let later on we hear the mention of the
Chrono
base Chrono Bay 3 Kang's home was
actually called chronopolis which itself
was located in the quantum realm might
be nothing might be all connected and
the quantum realm might even be where
the TVA is anyway in the present we see
Loki walk back into the room yes in the
future where Casey recognizes him
holding rule book this becomes something
that appears throughout the episode and
there's lots of things that the
characters learn from it Casey says as
long as I can remember as long as I can
remember highlight that something's been
done to his memory to hide the past in
which Kang ruled after the title
sequence we cut to where we last left
this version of Mobius and B15 wrestling
with the fact they've been murdering on
mass they grapple with how to inform the
TVA about what they're really up to xo5
then shows up and asks about Mobius jet
ski magazine which is something that
appeared in the first season he also
mentions judge gamble who's a play on
Justin gamble a character that comes
directly from the comics once a TVA
Professor he ended up turning his back
against the organization and this was in
order to stop a group known as the
incinerators the character was kind of
based on Doctor Who but it seems like
they're leaning in with it more just
being a judge she actually seems to
believe B5 story which could highlight
her turning against the organization
anyway we find out they're in the war
room and I took this as being a little
play on Doctor Strange Love War rooms
have of course always been a widely used
term which demonstrates how bad things
have gotten for the TVA a war room like
this appeared in fantastic 4353 and this
was where the team were brought to when
they were being judged as they head
towards it we can see a room of murals
and later on we get a better look at
what this is this is broken up into
three panels and it echoes the sisters
of Fate from Greek mythology they used
to control Destiny by pulling on the
threads of Life which the temporal Loom
might be building off the back of the
Loom of course pulson threads and the
timelines themselves are represented
like their part of a big piece of string
on the left panel we see the multiversal
war between all the ks with them
fighting it out to attain timeline
Supremacy throughout we can see them
standing on Hover platforms which the
villain used to get around on during
Quantum Mania a lot of humans we we can
see them running below and they do look
like they're all TVA members the second
one is the timekeepers constructing the
sacred timeline with the people below
praying to them like a god this shows
how indoctrinated the TVA are into it as
they blindly follow these gods and don't
question their faith and then the
timekeepers came along and saved us
[Music]
all these religious metaphors carry
across to the final panel where we can
see them standing with their hands
pressed together like a prayer the
timeline itself also looks like a tree
which is something we also saw in across
the spiderverse now just before hitting
the War Room Mobius bumps into the
soldier who pruned him during the middle
point of episode 4 Mia says yeah well I
guess you're just following orders which
is something that the SS used as an
excuse when explaining why they
committed the Holocaust and this idea of
following orders speaks to the TVA who
blindly do anything without questioning
the logic or Reason now we see his low
he enters the War Room in the past which
is where you can see lots of heads upon
the walls these actually represent the
judges and they end up remaining because
K never replaced them however what he
did is cover up that he was there and we
see that there's five versions of Kang's
head on the wall actually think this
represents the council with five of
these being different versions of him
these Echo Emperor's heads from Rome and
show how important that Kang views
himself as the armor and head pieces
also look slightly different as well
potentially highlighting these are
different versions of him in the comics
Kang actually worked with the council
and this happened before betraying them
and then becoming a mortise this is
possibly what what he he remains did and
the central head could belong to him now
speaking of heads we see the timekeeper
leaders in the future which was beheaded
during episode 4 this is in front of the
grand mural which itself has a Time Loom
at the center of it listening to your
recording of Loki explaining the truth
the judges all sit around trying to make
sense of it I love how we even catch one
as sleep and it kind of speaks to the
bureaucracy that we have to deal with in
real life now this tape recorder is also
used in the past with us hearing Kang's
proposal to
aona he said it he said it a pair will L
Us in the comments and we'll likely see
what happened with them in the series
mang says for all time with this
building into the tva's motto for all
time always jumping back to season 1 we
also had this in the episode titles with
it being the name of that final entry
was actually surprised at how much this
featured in the first season with the
same popping up at several times
throughout now Kang is clearly in love
and he very much wanted a real time with
him this was similar to how Loki and
Sylvie Were Meant to real together but
but as we know both ended up alone Kang
is kind of destined to be by himself and
this is something we explored in his new
origin story titled only myself left to
conquer this has a young Nathaniel
Richards getting found by his older self
trained by a bit of version he ended up
trying to escape and this was after he
met a woman from a local tribe this was
raona but the older Kang ended up
killing her which led to the young
version going down a darker path
throughout time he met several versions
of a reincarnated but he'd always turn
against him because of how he truly was
in the end Nathaniel turned into the bit
of man he first met and then went back
in time to meet Nathaniel and then start
the cycle again I'm guessing that Kang
became hero remains after she decided
not to join him and he kept her around
as a judge just out in the organization
in episode 2 we did hear about her
having another analyst that she met and
potentially this could turn out to be he
who remains Mobius what those Rings were
already there from your other fa analyst
going to remember this this must be from
that analyst you keep on the side either
way though something didn't work out and
then she was probably replaced by Miss
minutes who we see is a band in the TVA
now in the present B15 talks about how
everyone had a life on the timeline
which he discovered due to Ren slayer's
real one also I love how K tii General
dock say Tim keeper faces on her medals
and it kind of shows how much of a
facade this is she's the one who finds
it most difficult to accept because
she's clearly devoted heal life to
propping up the lie as they say it's
easier to scam someone than to tell them
they've been scammed and she's clearly
going to become one of the major
antagonists I also wonder if these
medals were attained during the
multiversal war as that's the only major
conflict when they could have been taken
might all just be a facade as there's
not been any real conflicts and yeah who
knows exactly what this is our name
General docs all supports from the
comics with her being a play on the
character Paradox this was one of the
judges that appeared during the She-Hulk
trial before he was erased from
existence with a retroactive Cannon she
says what in Earth are you suggest and
protect now Mt pointed out that
technically they're not on Earth but
this turn of phrase could show their
memories are coming through X5 also has
xent fire ridden on his gloves possibly
showing his narcissism which we'll talk
about later on there's lots of things
with him that they tease in the trailer
but I'll save that for the end in case
you guys don't want to know a B15 wants
them to take a stance and turn their
back on what they believe with gamble
even saying
I can do anything she ERS that they stop
pruning and then give the people on the
timeline of life now Loki walks in and
reveals the truth behind the mural
pruning it to wipe out this false
timeline it's kind of like when Hela
revealed the truth about Odin and it
shows the man who enslaved them for the
first time now X5 and darks put their
heads together which B15 reacts to
weirdly they might be in love you know
I'm I'm not here a judge it might be his
mother or something um and the pair
potentially might have been pulled from
a Time line to work together here there
aren't a lot of other people who would
be willing so shout out to one of my
favorite YouTubers heavy spoilers when
he says Theory time I'm telling you
don't who don't quote me on that mate
yeah it might not be his M but I don't
know still early doors episode one yeah
we're still throwing out loads of [__]
to see what sticks and it is a bit weird
that they kind of focus on this moment
now sylv's then ordered to be found
which does lead into what happens later
on loogi tells mbius about what's going
on and he also talks about how K was the
devil
to kill the
devil maybe he was this is something he
who remains refer to himself as and we
also had lots of biblical imagery with
him Loki and svie were standings for
Adam and Eve with him even tempting them
with the knowledge chule all time Kang
even appeared holding an apple riffing
on the snake in the Garden of Eden and
tempting Eve or Sylvie who who was the
one who pulled everything down also I
love how ly says it was a draw CU it's
like a bad breakup where you you want to
keep your dignity now finally sees
things from the point of view as he who
remains and sees it being better the
devil you know you then have to go to OB
and this takes them two lifts showing
how far out the way the character is
when they go to it they also have to
pass through a cafeteria which has
posters on the walls similar to ones
from World War II this says no chitchat
like loose lips sying ships and it also
tells you to limit your lunch break this
is the 17 minutes which like a bit weird
it's a very weirdly specific time but
obviously the TVA are super focused on
times so maybe this is like the perfect
amount for a lunch break to be we also
see a post man walking through the
corridors building off the back of the
one we caught in the truck a poster also
says catch a Nexus prevent a red line
building off the back of the Mis Minutes
video that was shown in episode one I
love the I have no memory of having my
memory wiped and these scenes they just
flow so well I I think the way the
camera moves with them and the whole
just the whole way the episode shot it
feels incredible and is expertly done it
just keeps up the dynamism of the scene
and adds an extra layer to how the
dialogue plays out when you think about
it this whole episode takes place in the
TVA and it's mainly people standing
about in rooms just talking about time
the way the camera moves though it helps
to elevate the scenes and all in all
makes this stand out much more than the
first season the direction in that was
often pretty straightforward but here we
get these long One-Shot takes that
really allow the scenes to shine now
down in the basement they meet Ora baros
who as we and repairs a TVA Tech this is
highlighted in a poster to the right
which is about repairing a temperamental
temp pad the name oroboros actually
means a snake that eats its own tail
which highlights an never ending cycle
of Destruction this is something that
the TVA constantly do with the
multiversal war being a stage of the
universe the way things go is that Kang
Rises up and all his varians fight it
out to gain Supremacy once one is won he
becomes he who remains and waits at the
end of time until a Loki shows up this
leads to their death which causes the
Multiverse to open up and the cycle
starts again beginning once more now in
the room mobus says it's been a while
since I've been down
here actually I'm not sure I've ever
been down here showing he's had his
memory wiped oras Obie didn't this is
how he remembers Loki visiting the past
whereas everyone else simply forgets it
we sort of get a brief idea of how long
ago it was with Mobius last visiting 400
years prior Mia seems to start to
remember it and it could show that the
memories may end up coming back kiuk
Kuan he kills it in the Sentry and he
basically becomes a tva's q kiuk Kuan of
course played data and The Goonies with
him also being an inventor in that as
well also he showed up in everything
everywhere all at once which he won the
Oscar for so he's got this this track of
doing multiversal things American Born
Chinese as well yeah no one watched it
but it is good so go and check it out
now I love how B10 puts in a request for
a Browning banana and this might be for
the lunch break where you've got 17
minutes mate and anyway orboros was
actually part of the She-Hulk trial too
with him being a clone of Mr Paradox
they're clearly not going in that
direction but I love the way that these
ideas are carrying over now the way that
we can help differentiate the two
versions is the one in the past doesn't
have the glasses we can also catch an
old Sprite vending machine and it's
possible that OB has him confused with
Mobius in the present he says that
Mobius called him Obi whereas in the
past we see that Loki gave him that name
it's also possible that the past and the
present both rely on each other due to
Loki's time traveling even might show
that Loki doing it in the past changes
things in the present slightly which is
why his memory then changes they know
that it's more in line with a bootstrap
Paradox which involves the past and
present both impacting each other in
this Theory a scientist one day gets a
knock at the door and they open it up to
find a book lying on the ground this
explains how they can build a time
machine which they then carry out and
travel back in time they then knock on
their own door and leave themselves the
book showing how the cycle can then
continue on it's lots of timey wiy
wibbly wobbly stuff and they also
mention the temporal Aura extractor
temporal auras were shown in the first
season with loi's being taken when he
enter the TVA the device will also allow
Loki to be pulled out of the time stream
and finally saved from the constant time
slipping I love how they keep talking
about Mobius getting his skin peeled off
which is a joke that they keep doing for
the rest of the entry they talk about
Loki being pruned and also say if you
fall into a black hole you'll turn into
spaghetti have you heard about how if
you fall into black told you turn into
spaghetti no good the less you know
about that the better this is basically
what's happening with Loki and even my
man Reed Richards became mom's spaghetti
realizing that the TVA is destabilizing
with a Time stream this is caused by
overloading the temporal Loom we see
what this looks like later on in the
entry with it appearing like a great
machine that pulls the threads together
this imagery was actually shown in
season one and about the 10-minute Mark
into episode 5 here we saw m minutes
showing the time stream with a branch
ing out into a rainbow like structure
like what we witness here they head
towards the access point and I was sat
wondering how many times they had to
shoot that bit where Loki catches the
book it's a detail index of every
mechanical classification of every
mechanical classification nice one mate
got it in one now just before they head
in we can see a warning on the floor
which talks about the dangers of
approaching the loom it says temporal
radiation levels escalate exponentially
Beyond this threshold likelihood of
spaghettification increases 7000% now
spaghettification makes sense if you
consider that the TVA exists in one of
the black holes in the lowkey season one
finale Mt is going to be breaking down
everything about these black holes in a
follow-up video so make sure you stay
locked cuz there there's a hell of a lot
of stuff that he talks about and yet the
idea of black holes is actually dotted
throughout the episode now it's such a
good scene with this being an amazing
way to take the entry that builds up the
tension as they try and save Loki Loki
then seems to travel into his own future
and he sees that sy's climbing out of an
elevator he was likely pruned by his
future self to send him back to where he
needed to go as this is an older version
of Sylvie who isn't the one we meet in
the post credit scene in that we see her
traveling out to McDonald's and this is
the version from when she just killed he
who remains she was finally free from
the TVA and as we know Sylvia was
someone who was hunted throughout her
life and had to hide out at apocalypses
in order to survive now though she's
able to roam free and the first thing
she does is go to a McDonald's I believe
that the one in the elevator is a future
version of her interacting with Loki
from the future and that she's mistaking
the one in the present with him from the
future there you are theory on this but
I think that a Loki from a future
episode steps in and then prunes himself
so he gets sent back to the loom I'd
love it if that was the case and then
we'd have the bootstrap Paradox playing
out across multiple entries ly from the
future would know this would need to
happen and thus he'd carry it out to
make sure things keep in line she
clearly mistakes the two but the future
version here probably prunes himself
which then sends him back feel like
we'll see more of this scene in a future
episode and it'll bring it all together
with Loki pruning himself he knows he
needs to do this so that he can be there
at this moment so prunes himself to keep
time
consistent hope that makes sense and the
heat is on with them just having five
minutes while Doc's crew ride the Armory
to go after selfie Mobius has put in
what looks like a bomb disposal suit and
it's such a cool way to take things for
the Final Act now Loki jumps ahead and
we know this is minutes from now due to
the crack in the window and the skin
written in dust thus they may travel
back to this moment to help secure other
things and the fight could be about them
taking docks
down
time time W wibbly wobbly stuff but I
actually think that docs may be raiding
the Armory because they attack at this
point this is when the TVA is at its
weakest so it makes sense Loki and
Sylvie would travel here to make a big
strike also yeah if you enjoying the
video and want to support the channel we
just launched a Loki inspired t-shirt
that if you don't get you're going to
get your clock cleaned we've also got
lots of theory time ones and other
franchises on there like House of the
Dragon Ahsoka Ant-Man and a lot more all
goes towards keeping the lights on and
helping us stay independent so we can
keep making videos for you like this
without our evil corporate overlords
telling us what to do these timelines
will not be proved but yeah if you if
you enjoy it please support anyway
that's the end of the time a time time
for all all time
always now I love the way they have an
Old World War II air raid siren as Mia
steps
out this immediately heightens attention
and with it coming from Altech it makes
sense to pull this across mobus ends up
putting the device in and this acts as a
harpoon eventually pulling loia and into
one stable place as you run through the
offices in order to warn Sylvie we also
see that the time looms bringing the
branches in together on the screen this
could be killing the Multiverse out in
the main World though they did kind of
go against that due to what they said
either way though lots of mysteries with
what's happening with Sylvie and you can
tell that L he's still desperate to see
her from what she says they obviously
reunite and we also have that ringing
phone which draws his attention he may
even be calling himself at this point to
pull himself towards it and this is so
that he can be in the place where he can
be pruned Obi locks stuff down and we
then see Mobius arrive which is when is
pulled out safely he says that they need
to find Sylvie and then we see X5 and
his forces mounting up his men Doc is
joining them too and we catch the death
squad moving out to put an end to her
they're arming up with lots of pruning
charges showing they plan to wipe out
all the numerous timelines now the
credits of the show have a lot going on
with them and with his being the first
time seeing them I thought we'd break
them down then talk about the post cred
scene and all the shots in the trailer
before going over our review and what we
think of the episode
now there's the same lucky file from
season 1 but this is then coupl by a
timekeep ahead cut to some Post-it notes
which talk about a pool of deception
potentially ripping on the lies with the
timekeepers they also talk about the
secret of the dark Mountain which is
possibly a reference to mount wo also
mentions Jen's betrayal and the flaxian
calendar a re-echoed sound and the boy
betrayed the tower keeper this could be
a know about he who remains with Loy
potentially being the one who betrayed
him though it's more likely Sylvie which
is not man now one of the clocks also
says Kronos per hours with that being
time in the TVA there's also the pies
that appear in the trailer one of which
Mobius ends up pulling out now there's
Mis minutes and the schematics for a
Time Loom which we see Victor timley
Building during the trailer there's also
the book black holes the end of the
universe which is by the author John G
Miller this is again potentially
pointing to the black holes at the end
of time which is possibly where the TVA
is located other books in the background
include the final program by Matthew Mok
and the Phoenix obsidian by the same
author you also see the Infinity Stones
a coffee machine Obie's light flickering
off and on with a hollow projector 35
making an appearance too this is what
Loki watches live back on in season 1
and they used to interrogate all the
time deviants there also the zotan
contingent which is a book that doesn't
seem to exist in real life but it seems
like it's connected to ob's character as
the actor's name shows up in this Frame
there's a model of Mobius suit which may
also show them planning this in the
future so that they're able to then go
and do it in the past then there's W
Magazine with the jet skis along with
some photos from the episode and a crack
in the floor you also to see MacDonald's
2 and the murals of the timekeepers with
mis minutes on his temp pad and the he
who remains Castle this is empty with
his hand of ice lying there showing
what's happening in the wake of his
death I also think we get a sling ring
too and the official TVA handbook before
we cut to the murals and lastly this
leads us into the post crit scene where
we watch Sylvia arriving at the
McDonald's for the first time we see
that this is a branch timeline with the
bottom telling us it's the N 1982
Brockton is actually a big location in
the comics and this is where the home of
new Asgard was happening in Oklahoma
this is where Sylvia attacked before and
it was here she made her first
appearance back in season 1 I love going
back here cuz I remember these
McDonald's where used to they used to
have birthday sections yeah kids and you
could go and sit under that creepy tree
and eat your little Happy Meal those
were days no juding by what she says not
squirrel not possum not rats something
that's already dead and nothing with a
face she's clearly had to hunt these
herself and has been going on for
decades desperate to survive I also get
the feeling she kind of Misses Loki
which is cemented by her looking
longingly at the couple now going into
the trailer teasers we also know she
ends up working here and that Loki
arrives to see her again Loki and
McDonald's they've got a big promotion
going on at the moment and you can even
get these little themed sources that
have well well depending on where you
buy them one you you going to see some
Easter eggs in England yeah you have to
by law put the ingredients on something
and H yeah that's why the the UK label
looks like a complete mess I'm never
going to read but yeah the American one
looks nice at least and the trailer
looks like it shows X5 as a movie star
attending a premiere for his film The
ziac this is actually a character from
the comics and I think he's realized
that with all these timelines branching
out he's now able to change things and
basically go and live the high life as
you said before he has X in five on his
gloves which was kind of hinting that he
he is a bit of a narcissist now the
trailer also shows stuff getting
spaghetti fied and the forces of Kate
dicki's docks hunting sylv and Loki you
also have them traveling to Victor
timely which is where we see the time
Loom on stage being showed lastly
there's a moment where they move the
bomb suit along the walkway which is
clearly ripping on Mobius doing in this
episode at the end though we can see
Victor timely which could be showing
that they planned this whole thing out
and how things would operate it could
also be a heist as well with them going
over what's happened and yeah if that
was Loki who pruned himself then we
could be returning to this time in
location so lots of stuff to look
forward to and as for this episode I
think it was just a great way to start
the season they really put their all
into the production and again I can't
Hammer home how much the direction and
the way the camera moves elevates it all
takes what could just be basic and then
creates tension dynamism and an energy
to the scenes that makes it gripping to
watch I love the back and forth stuff
happening through time as well and it
kept the episode constantly developing
with new twists and turns the dialogue
was really fresh as well there was lots
of comedic moments but you you also got
the sense like guys we really need to
get on with this I am back to Shilling
but after so many Duds and meth releases
from Marvel and Disney plus I feel Faith
that the franchise is getting back on
track they don't waste any time hitting
the ground running and they instantly
pick up where we left up and don't drop
the pace also love how there's this
constant mystery as as well with just
getting more questions and answers over
what's going on overall it was a great
way to start off and I can't wait to
discuss it for the next 6 weeks please
drop a like and if you want to support
the channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out now if you want
something else to watch we've got the
Ahsoka finale breakdown on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this lots of things to talk about
yeah I'm sure you watched it if you
watched this channel so yeah definitely
head over there right after this by the
way huge thank you for sing through the
video I've been Paul I'll see you next
time you take care
[Music]
peace